un instinto así podría tener consecuencias,
porque lo primero que descubrí es que no soy solo yo.
En 2007 el Washington Post informó que los militares de EE. UU.
estaban probando el robot que desactivaba minas terrestres.
Y funcionaba con la forma de un insecto palo,
caminando sobre sus piernas alrededor de un campo minado
y cada vez que pisaba una mina, una de las piernas explotaba,
y seguía sobre las restantes piernas para hacer explotar más minas.
Y el coronel a cargo de este ejercicio de prueba
terminó suspendiendo,
porque decía que era demasiado inhumano
ver a ese robot dañado arrastrarse por el campo minado.
Y ¿qué causaría que un oficial militar endurecido
y alguien como yo
tuviéramos esa reacción a los robots?
Por supuesto, estamos preparados por la ciencia ficción y la cultura pop
a querer de verdad personificar estas cosas,
pero esto es un poco más profundo que eso.
Resulta que estamos biológicamente programados
para proyectar intencionalidad y vida
a cualquier movimiento en nuestro espacio físico que nos parezca autónomo.
Así que la gente tratará todo tipo de robots como si estuvieran vivos.
Estas unidades de eliminación de bombas obtienen nombres.
Obtienen medallas de honor.
Les han homenajeado con funerales con salvas.
Y la investigación muestra que lo hacemos incluso con robots domésticos muy simples,
como la aspiradora Roomba.
(Risas)
Es solo un disco que vaga por el piso para limpiarlo,
pero el hecho de que se está moviendo de forma autónoma
hará que la gente le denomine el Roomba
y se sienta mal por el Roomba cuando se atasca debajo del sofá.
(Risas)
Y podemos diseñar concretamente robots para evocar esta respuesta,
usando ojos y caras o movimientos.
para que la gente automáticamente y subconscientemente lo asocie
con estados de ánimo.
Y hay todo un cuerpo de investigación denominado interacción humano-robot
que muestra realmente lo bien que funciona esto.
Por ejemplo, los investigadores de la Universidad de Stanford descubrieron
que la gente se siente realmente incómoda
cuando se les pide tocar las partes íntimas de un robot.
(Risas)
A partir de esto y a partir de muchos otros estudios,
sabemos que las personas responden a las señales que reciben
a través de estas máquinas realistas,
incluso sabiendo que no son reales.
Nos dirigimos hacia un mundo donde los robots estarán en todas partes.
La robótica se está moviendo desde detrás de las paredes de la fábrica.
Está entrando a los lugares de trabajo, a los hogares.
Y como esas máquinas pueden percibir y tomar decisiones autónomas y aprender,
entran en estos espacios compartidos.
Creo que tal vez la mejor analogía que tenemos para esto
es nuestra relación con los animales.
Hace miles de años comenzamos a domesticar animales,
y los entrenamos para el trabajo, la guerra y la compañía.
Y a lo largo de la historia hemos tratado a algunos animales
como herramientas o productos similares.
y a otros animales los hemos tratado con amabilidad.
Y les hemos dado un lugar en la sociedad como nuestros compañeros.
Creo entonces plausible comenzar a integrar robots de manera similar.
Y claro, los animales están vivos.
Los robots no.
Y les puedo decir, por mi trabajo en robótica.
que estamos bastante lejos de desarrollar robots que puedan sentir.
Pero sentimos por ellos,
y eso importa,
Porque si intentamos integrar robots en estos espacios compartidos,
hay que entender que
las personas los tratarán de manera diferente a otros dispositivos,
y que, en algunos casos,
por ejemplo, el caso de un soldado que se une emocionalmente
al robot con el que trabaja,
puede ser desde ineficiente hasta peligroso.
Pero en otros casos, en realidad, puede ser útil
fomentar esta conexión emocional con los robots.
Ya estamos viendo algunos buenos casos de uso,
Por ejemplo, robots que trabajan con niños autistas.
para involucrarlos en formas que no se han visto antes o
robots que trabajan con maestros
para involucrar a los niños en el aprendizaje con nuevos resultados.
Y no solo para niños.
Los primeros estudios muestran que los robots pueden ayudar
a médicos y pacientes en entornos sanitarios.
Este es el robot de foca bebé PARO.
Se utilizan en hogares de ancianos y con pacientes con demencia
y ya se aplican hace algún tiempo.
Y recuerdo, hace años estar en una fiesta
contándole a alguien sobre este robot,
y su respuesta fue,
"Oh Dios mío.
Esto es horrible.
No puedo creer estar dando a las personas robots en vez de cuidado humano".
Y esta es una respuesta muy común,
y creo que es absolutamente correcto,
porque eso sería terrible.
Pero en este caso, no es lo que reemplaza este robot.
Lo que este robot reemplaza es la terapia animal.
En contextos donde no podemos usar animales reales,
podemos usar robots, porque la gente
los tratará de forma más parecida a un animal que a un dispositivo.
Reconocer esta conexión emocional con los robots
también nos puede ayudar a anticipar desafíos, porque
estos dispositivos se mueven hacia áreas más íntimas de la vida de las personas.
Por ejemplo, ¿está bien si el robot de oso de peluche de su hijo
graba conversaciones privadas?
¿Está bien si su robot sexual tiene compras atractivas dentro de la app?
(Risas)
Porque los robots más capitalismo es igual a
preguntas sobre la protección del consumidor y la privacidad.
Y esas no son las únicas razones para que
nuestro comportamiento relacionado con estas máquinas pueda ser relevante.
Unos años antes de esa primera experiencia inicial
con este robot dinosaurio bebé,
hice un taller con mi amigo Hannes Gassert.
Y tomamos cinco de estos robots bebé dinosaurio
y se los dimos a cinco equipos de personas.
Y les pedimos que los nombraran
y jugaran e interactuaran con ellos durante aproximadamente una hora.
Y luego les dimos un martillo y un hacha
y les dijimos que torturaran y mataran a los robots.
(Risas)
Y esto resultó ser un poco más dramático.
de lo que esperábamos,
porque ninguno de los participantes lo hizo eso
a estos robots dinosaurios bebé,
así que tuvimos que improvisar un poco, y en un momento dijimos,
"Bien, pueden salvar el robot de su equipo si destruyen el robot de otro equipo".
(Risas)
E incluso eso no funcionó. No querían hacerlo.
Así que finalmente, dijimos,
"Vamos a destruir todos los robots
a no ser que alguien destruya con un hacha uno de ellos".
Y un tipo se puso de pie y tomó el hacha,
y toda la habitación se estremeció cuando dio un hachazo
en el cuello del robot,
y hubo un momento de silencio medio jocoso, medio serio en la habitación
por este robot muerto.
(Risas)
Fue una experiencia realmente interesante.
No era un estudio controlado, obviamente,
pero condujo a una investigación posterior que hice en el MIT
con Palash Nandy y Cynthia Breazeal,
donde hubo personas que vinieron al laboratorio y aplastaron a estos HEXBUGs
que se mueven de manera muy realista, como los insectos.
Así que en lugar de elegir algo lindo que atrae a la gente,
elegimos algo más básico.
Y lo que descubrimos fue que las personas de alta empatía
dudaban más en golpear a los HEXBUGS.
Esto es solo un pequeño estudio,
pero es parte de un gran cuerpo de investigación.
Eso está empezando a indicar que puede haber una conexión
entre las tendencias de empatía de las personas
y su comportamiento en torno a los robots.
Pero mi pregunta para la era venidera de la interacción humano-robot
no es: "¿Simpatizamos con los robots?",
sino: "¿Pueden los robots cambiar la empatía de las personas?".
¿Hay alguna razón para, por ejemplo,
evitar que su hijo patee a un perro robótico,
no solo por respeto a la propiedad, sino porque
el niño podría ser más propenso a patear a un perro de verdad?
Y de nuevo, no son solo niños.
Esta es la pregunta sobre los videojuegos violentos,
pero a un nivel completamente nuevo,
debido a esta fisicalidad visceral a la que respondemos más intensamente
que a las imágenes en una pantalla.
Cuando nos comportamos violentamente hacia los robots,
concretamente robots diseñados para imitar la vida,
¿es esta una salida saludable para el comportamiento violento
o significa entrenar nuestros músculos para la crueldad?
Nosotros no lo sabemos.
Sin embargo, la respuesta a esta pregunta
tiene el potencial de impactar el comportamiento humano,
tiene el potencial de impactar normas sociales,
tiene el potencial de inspirar reglas sobre lo que podemos
y no podemos hacer con ciertos robots,
similar a nuestras leyes de crueldad animal.
Porque incluso si los robots no pueden sentir,
nuestro comportamiento hacia ellos puede ser importante para nosotros.
Y sin importar si terminamos cambiando nuestras reglas,
los robots podrían ayudarnos a llegar a una nueva comprensión de nosotros mismos.
La mayor parte de lo que he aprendido en los últimos 10 años,
no es tecnología en absoluto,
sino psicología humana
empatía y cómo nos relacionamos con los demás.
Porque cuando un niño es amable con un Roomba,
cuando un soldado trata de salvar a un robot en el campo de batalla,
o cuando un grupo de personas se niega a dañar a un bebé dinosaurio robótico,
esos robots no son solo motores, engranajes y algoritmos,
son reflejos de nuestra propia humanidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)